hey everybody it's Charlie! we got to talk all
about infinity war inhumans crossover
and a bunch of you requested I do shield
stuff so i added that to the end of this
Marvel stuff blowing up all over this
year so there's a whole bunch of stuff
to explain but if you're new to the
channel i do Marvel videos for the
movies for the TV shows for the comics
every week be sure to subscribe to get
everything i do giveaways every week to
that i'll explain at the end of the
video where the big things going on here
it will start with inhuman Avengers
infinity war crossover stuff then i'll
talk about agents of shield a big WTF
with a cliffhanger they're basically
ending this block of episodes the lmd
block and they're going to move into
something else but there was a big twist
and you guys are requesting a video so
I'll explain that after i do infinity
war in human so the big deal with inhumans
is that Ramsay Bolton from Game
of Thrones was just cast as Maximus the
met the brother of Black Bolt sort of
the loci of that family you have to
remember that the Inhumans kind of like
this weird offshoot group the x-men were
always the most popular characters in
the comics the Inhumans this is actually
really funny started during Fantastic
Four I've done a couple inhumans videos
in the past like what agents of shield
sort of pushing into that storyline but
the deal with the TV show is that it's
not being designed as an agent of shield
spin-off it's completely separate it's
an eight-episode miniseries it might get
like 13 episodes in season 2 that does
really well which is it sounds like it
will in its getting ready to film in
hawai i did a video about name or little
while ago because there's like a mystery
Marvel project that's filming down there
but they've just started casting the
series so we don't know who Black Bolt
is but we know who Maximus's they
confirm they're doing the entire royal
family and if you look at the age of
Randy Bolton here you can guess at the
age of the rest of the characters the
showrunner is the same guy that did iron
fist
so this is all Marvel television it's
not marvel film division but they're
going to be rolling out a whole bunch
more information about the cast will be
like the next big thing that everybody
learns who are playing all these
characters who's gonna be Black Bolt
who's going to be Medusa who's going to
be Karnak i'm actually really excited
about carnet but obviously Black Bolt is
the big deal but the big problem that
Marvel has isn't how it explains their
origin story and how they're only now
just making themselves known
so in the Marvel Universe they've been
around this whole
I'm in Atlanta their city has been
cloaked from view it's changed its
location a couple of times like it
started out on the far side of the mood
then it went below the ocean then it
went above New York City after the
Infinity art so there's a lot of
problems that they can solve by the
streamlining their origin story in tying
it with infinity war now the movies
usually don't cross over with the TV
shows the TV shows are free to borrow
whatever they want though it is a very
connected universe but it's kind of a
one-sided connectedness so even though
this inhuman shows like a really big
deal i'm not expecting to see any of
them in infinity work they haven't even
shot it yet so Kevin Feige
behind-the-scenes probably has a few
ideas about how he'll connecting so what
they might end up doing because the show
is going to drop before infinity war
drops infinity war the movie is 2018
this show is going to premiere this sep
tember it's gonna be badass is that a
piggyback on the Civil War sokovia
accords that slowly bring them into the
limelight and then in the second season
they can address the blowback of
infinity war which actually was a big
thing in the comic if you remember the
Terrigen Bob from infinity they try to
do a version of that on agents of shield
with the fish oil pills I wasn't a big
fan with a twist but they were trying to
do their own version of that where they
just create a whole bunch of Inhumans
all at the same time so this show is
going to start out relatively
self-contained but it exists in the MCU
so what they might do is just piggyback
on some of the comic book infinity twist
whereby panos does some really big
damage issues big threats to the earth
give me the infinity gems or else we
have the plot of infinity war shit gets
crazy what happened in the comics is a
no threatened to destroy at the land
unless blackbolt gave him tribute by
killing all inhumans between ages 16
and 22 status was actually looking for
his son at the time now they're probably
not going to do in the movies so don't
worry about some of the details but in
answer to his challenge blackbolt set
off a Terrigen bomb activating dormant
inhumans all over the earth so you just
have to have some sort of impetus for
Inhumans to be a big deal in the world
of the humans and what they might do is
they'll start off relatively slow the
way they did invent
fantastic four like it was very
secretive you only knew about the couple
of inhumans that were members of the
royal family but then you learn about
their race how they been hiding out this
whole time so that's probably what's
going to happen at the land will be
featured in a series the way it was not
featured on agents of shield that was a
huge bummer and a lot of your asking
does that mean that shield characters
will get the crossover with the Inhumans
TV show in as far as i know that is not
the case
anything could change but the way they
explained it is that the inhuman show is
not a spin-off is designed to be its own
thing so they won't be forced to deal
with any of the twists or turns the
shield has set up so they don't have to
deal with fish oil pills or anything
like that and we don't even know which
time period is going to be setting they
could actually choose to set this way in
the past so Black Bolt is actually about
the same age as tony stark and a lot of
the other main Avengers characters so
you have to imagine that if he showed up
in the movie he a much older character
so since these are younger and it's
something of an origin story for the
blackpool character and what we see on
the TV show during season one might
actually take place like 20 or 30 years
ago just depending on how old they want
to make them in modern continuity it
would probably be a tease or nineties
because they don't want to make them so
old that he's like an old man compared
to tony stark and the other Avengers but
i'm really excited I'm totally happy
with the casting I think that he's
perfect for Maximus the mad he plays
crazy characters so well if you don't
remember he actually played a pretty
crazy character on this british series
called misfits whole bunch of juvenile
offenders get superpowers and it's sort
of like a Suicide Squad situation where
they try to do good things and some of
them are good some of them are bad but
anyway it's going to be great will do
plenty of Inhumans videos this summer if
there any specific bonus videos you want
me to do for that
just let me know in the comments like
that Avengers infinity war piano stuff
will inform a lot of what they do in
future seasons but because these in one
of the show is coming first they don't
have to deal with it too much and it's
not connected to agents of shield so
next big thing
agents of shield WTF so just careful for
spoilers from episode 15 of shield will
talk about a couple of the really big
twist and explain what's going on what
they're moving into in what's going to
be happening with season 5 because the
show is not
been renewed yet in there a couple
different scenarios but i do think that
they can get more episodes I don't think
they'll cancel the show but here's the
big deal so at the end of the episode we
learned that they're all getting sucked
into the matrix
daisy has to help rescue them with
Simmons and a couple people that are
left on the outside the superior is now
like the Modoc of the show he's like the
head in a jar controlling a life model
decoy version of himself in a Radcliffe
is dead
the interesting thing there were a lot
of deaths in the episode but Radcliffe
is the only main character that
genuinely got killed off so he's inside
the matrix now his consciousness still
exists he's still a character on the TV
show but the big twist is the stuff
inside the matrix that a piece agents of
Hydra the flash this big logo and
everyone's like what does it mean what's
going on
so the whole idea is that the matrix is
supposed to be this version of reality
that rolls back everyone's regrets so
the one regret and I think the big twist
here the Hydra twist is that Coulson
never joined shield that was his one
regret
so he's this professor here there's that
creepy music from the beginning of the
episode playing it seems like everyone
is enjoying themselves even may who is
in the Triskelion which hasn't been
destroyed has the big Hydra symbol on it
seems like she is satisfied with what's
going on
it's meant to show how important Colton
is to the Marvel Universe he's the one
that brought the Avengers together that
were able to defeat loci that helped
inspire captain america to bring down
Hydra during winter soldier so like none
of those things ended up happening we
learned the superiors beat against
Coulson was that he felt like he was the
one that connected all of these crazy
events across all the movies all the
past seasons of the show you were here
you're the one common denominator with
all these things like there's a picture
of Thor's hammer
there's iron man stuff pretty much every
time that Coulson has popped up in the
movies as well as the big stuff on the
TV show
meaning that Coulson is the most
important person in the marvel universe
according to this big twist hopefully
that explains the big hydrate twist but
as a consequence of that word is still
alive so we're going to continue to see
dead characters pop up in the final
seven episodes
did say that it was going to be like a
love letter to the fan if you've been
watching the show for a long time
there'll be a lot of deep cuts they
might bring graviton bats and then
obviously there's the ghost rider stuff
left over because he got sucked into the
Dark Dimension he's going to have to
find his way back eventually it will
have something to do with wrapping up
the dark hold plot because that's the
common denominator that find all of
these story arcs the dark hold itself
it's the big MacGuffin of the season so
the real big thing here is that people
are wondering does that mean if inhumans
the TV show is coming is it going
to replace agents of shield in the
schedule because it's not a spin off its
way more expensive and it seems like
it's going to be way more popular at
least at the outset because it's a big
action set-pieces going to be shot like
a movie on imax cameras there even
screening the first two episodes and
imax that's how big it's going to be so
the president of ABC was talking about
this means like I feel like shield can
coexist within human so it's not their
intention to replace shield but because
ratings are declining what they might
end up doing like worst-case scenario
because they haven't hit a hundred
episodes yet in at the big benchmark for
TV is that the Leslie's give them a
partial season five renewal and we'll do
like 12 or 13 episodes and then that
will be the final season of shield don't
worry about it too much now it's not
that big a deal we're getting ready to
ramp up for iron fist and all the Marvel
movies that are coming this year so
schedule change because i'm probably not
going to do more Legion videos till
after the series is done like I'll wait
till after episode eight years to do
more Legion i'm going to make Thursday's
in Avengers day so there will be a
couple other days of the week that i
bookmark for special videos i'll let you
guys know when I update the schedule
there is a new round of the doctor
strange DVD giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber leave a
comment on this video
congratulations to last week's giveaway
winner shoe loud please private message
me on the back into my channel so i can
get your contact details
what's going to happen next is i'll post
my combined arrow legends of tomorrow
video and then have some brand-new
really cool for ragnarok stuff to post
while you wait for that you can click
here to rewatch that doctor strange
post-credits scene and you can click
here for all about that mystery Namor
project
thank you so much for watching let's
high-five i'll see you guys in the next video!